You're my neighbor.
You guys friends?
Oh, okay.
Got a pretty cool pretty fly car. Mo, I
always love the Beamer.
Yeah. Yeah, for sure. Love to burn some
rubber in that guy.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing
this book we haven't talked about it
very much. kitabiliz
is essentially at its core
a simplified
abridged
rendition of
by say
I think that many of the older
perhaps the older brothers the older
Arab brothers may have heard or know
are familiar with
Sunnah. It was authored sometime in
the 70s and 80s by a scholar of Fel from
Alhar
University and it gained worldwide rec
recognition very quickly and it became
very common place in almost every
masid, almost every home. It's a very
popular book. However, every
good book, every work of art truly,
everything that is
that is
I I don't want to say cutting edge. I
mean, it's not he discovered some
new thing about Phil.
The knowledge and the discipline of Fil
is of course 1500 years long.
However,
the key to this book and why it gained
such popularity, one of the reasons is
because the books of Fuk are written
with very particular terminologies.
And a person who is not familiar with
these terminologies
will grossly misunderstand what the
discuss and debate in their books.
Say
was able to kind of bridge that gap
to the general masses by taking a lot of
those terminologies, a lot of those
rulings, a lot of those books of folk
and simplifying them, organizing them
and you know kind of summarizing them
for the general reader, the average
Muslim, someone who is not necessarily a
scholar or even a student of knowledge.
And so any person could really pick
it up and understand for the most part
what the conclusions he arrived at
were. And so it was a very impressive
work, but it's not perfect. the
scholars of his time, his contemporaries
accepted this book holistically in
general and many books were written
trying to summarize it or a bridge it or
authenticate it or what have you and
this is one of those books.
oftent times when someone asks
you know if I want to read a book on
but I you know I don't know anything I'm
an average Muslim I want to read a book
on where should I start a good starting
place is by say it's
and alhamdulillah it has been translated
into many many many languages
because of its popularity ity and
it has also been summarized successfully
and Alajis is one of those books that
summarizes it. Basically it takes the
issue takes the gist of it mentions
the most prominent evidence for that
particular opinion and moves on and
so it's very summarized its name
its name is what Elajis
the
simplified in a nutshell if you will
right and so it's a very good book and I
believe waj has been translated as well
so If you're interested in that, talk
to me. Inshallah, we will arrange
making it available
and it depends on the five or the four
of Islam and does not usually go outside
of those four. So we are talking about
fasting. There's an narration on the
authority of Abi which we'll deal with
this evening with respect to the virtues
of fasting. The virtues of fasting. A
lot of times when something is
obligatory
the obligatory prayers, like
fasting Ramadan, giving zaka, often
times people will fail to recognize
the immense reward that is involved
because it's obligatory. So it kind of
becomes just a part of life. It's just
something that we do and we don't really
feel as much gratification
in the five daily prayers as we would
in
right to for instance or we wouldn't
feel as much gratification in Ramadan as
we would fasting outside of Ramadan. we
wouldn't feel as much gratification and
satisfaction in giving zaka which is
obligatory or supporting our family
that our dependence
as we would in giving additional
charity to some cause and it's actually
the opposite the greatest reward is
always found in the obligations the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam tells
us that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
himself has said
[Silence]
he said subhanah in the
my servant my slave gains nearness to me
with nothing more beloved to me than
that which I have obligated upon on him.
That is the most rewarding. The highest
reward is found in fulfillment of the
obligations.
He said, "And then and then after a
person fulfills the obligatory,
my servant continues to gain nearness to
me with optional acts of worship until I
come to love him. And if I love if I
come to love my servant,
[Silence]
He said, "And if I come to love my
slave,
then I will become his hearing with
which he hears and his sight with which
he sees. I will become his hand with
which he grasps and his foot upon which
he walks and if he asks me and his foot
with which he walks and if he asks me I
will answer and respond and if he seeks
refuge in me I will grant him refuge.
This is the way that we gain nearness to
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala. So a lot of
times we kind of overlook the obligation
of Ramadan and it's kind of you
know it's just something that we have to
do but the greatest reward is found in
the obligations of Islam. Abu
narrates to us that the messenger of
Allah.
Wasam said this hadith is a kudi hadith
and audi hadith is any narration in
which the prophet sallall.aii Wasam
narrates to us that Allah said that
Allah did something that is ascribed to
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
He said, "All of the acts of worship
that the human being performs are for
him except for fasting. It is for me and
I personally reward the servant for it."
What does that mean? All of the acts of
worship are for him except for fasting.
It is for me.
[Silence]
We cannot benefit Allah. We cannot
increase him in any way. We just as we
can't decrease him or deplete him in any
way. So what does this mean? Except for
fasting, it is for me.
The scholars mention two meanings to
this narration and both meanings are
correct.
The meaning that we're going to focus on
is most appropriate for this wording of
the narration
and that is that imagine with me if a
person wanted to use his acts of worship
to gain notoriety. Could he do that?
for instance, I want to pray and I
want to be at the masid every salah in
the first row. So people come to know me
as a very righteous man who's always at
the masid. That's the driving intention.
Could a person do that? could they
somehow benefit in a worldly gain from
their worship of Allah? Yes. Person
could give charity so that they be known
as generous. Person could make hajj as a
kind of notch in his belt so that he be
known as a hajj. A person could seek
knowledge so that he'd be known as a
scholar. A person can go and fight in
jihad in war in order to be known as a
person of valor and bravery and a person
who fights except for fasting. Why is
that? Fasting is woo.
Nobody knows if you're really fasting
except for except for you, from human
being, from humankind. I could eat a
five course meal.
I could eat a meal till I'm busting at
the seams and then come out to the masid
and say, "I'm so hungry. I am fasting."
And who would know the difference?
No one.
So if I maintain that fasting in private
as I do in public, what is the only
possible driving force for that?
It is Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala. That's
it. It's wudoo. And this is why the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam tells us as
a litmus test for e. What is eman? He
says
it is only the true believer who
maintains his wudoo. Who knows if you
have wudoo or not? No one. You're the
only human being who knows.
And so a person could hypothetically
pray for a decade without woo and none
would be the wiser. The only person who
maintains woodoo
and if he breaks it re remakes it and
maintains his woo in his purity is a
believer someone who believes that this
is an act of worship and Allah is
observing and fasting is no different.
So it's really a secret
between you and Allah. When you fast,
it's a very intimate secret between
yourself and Allah. There's no
middleman. There's no one that is
interfering
or interceding between yourself and
Allah. It's very direct. And for this
reason, Allah says, "Except for fasting,
it is for me. If a person fasts, it's
only because of Allah. and I personally
reward the person fasting
Allahbar. What does that mean? That
means that instead of the king having
his other servants, his angels reward
you, he himself
will reward you directly. Subhanahu
wa'ta'ala. Why? Because it is something
between you and Allah. That act of
worship is only for him and so only he
will reward you for fasting. This is an
incredible virtue of fasting that few
other if any acts of worship hold.
And so every time you fast it draws you
near Allah in a way that no other act of
worship can do. And that's why fasting
has been obligated upon every nation
that has come before us. Every
messenger, every messenger from
to Muhammad sallall.aii wasallam. How
many messengers were sent to the earth?
Huh?
125.
No. Huh? 315 messengers.
315 messengers. Each of them came with a
book. Each of them came with miracles.
Each of them came and each of them came
with fasting. Some iteration of fasting.
Did it have the exact same parameters as
our fasting? Now the details may differ,
but fasting was always a part of every
believer's journey to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. No matter how much you pray, it
can't take the place of fasting. No
matter how much charity you give, it
matter how much Hajj you give. Even
jihad itself cannot take the place of
fasting. And so fasting is for Allah and
Allah alone. And for this reason, Allah
will personally
reward you for fasting. you by name, you
individually, he will reward you for
your fasting. He says,
now that's a great reward, right? So, we
want to make sure that we keep and
retain our gains. Correct? We don't want
to be pouring water into a jug that has
no bottom to it.
So when you look at the top, a lot of
water is going in, but none of it is
what? None of it is being retained. Why?
Because we've cut the bottom out. How do
we cut the bottom out of our
proverbial jug of worship? by destroying
the reward,
by invalidating the reward.
A person who doesn't eat or drink
anything, doesn't engage in sexual
activity until the sunset from the break
of dawn with the intention of fasting.
This person has technically fasted.
However, does that mean that they've
been rewarded for fasting? No. Reward
is only gauged by your refraining from
sin. The more you sin fasting, the more
your reward depletes until a person will
be fasting in body and have no reward.
Listen to this haunting narration. The
prophet sallall.aii wasallam said
for
[Silence]
So we understand the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said there are some that
will fast and the only thing they
achieve by fasting is hunger. That's it.
Imagine how devastating you're
resurrected in front of Allah. You look
to your
reward for fasting, it's not there. It's
gone. There's none of it. Why? Where did
it go? It was invalidated by sin.
Even though you technically fasted.
Technically, sure.
But fasting of the body is only supposed
to act as a
as a conduit for the soul to fast. The
soul fasts from sin. The eyes fast, the
ears fast, the tongue fasts, the body
fasts, the heart fasts, the mind fasts.
And so
this is a great reward except for
fasting. It is for me alone and I will
personally reward for it. Hence,
hence, therefore,
if any of you is fasting
on a day, then he is not to be vulgar.
He is not to be loud
and he is not to be ignorant.
Those are three things he says.
So is vulgarity,
cursing, cursing, speaking about illicit
things, right? Using your tongue to say
bad things.
A is that a person is loud and obnoxious
and unruly.
This is called
he says
[Silence]
mashi
What is ignorance? The same meaning we
have in in English. Ignorance is that a
person behave ignorantly.
Argumentative, unreasonable, unruly,
obnoxious.
This is what we call.
And so these three things will
invalidate your reward.
Vulgarity,
inappropriateness,
unruliness,
loud.
Some people naturally speak loud. You
got to curb that, right?
Some people as soon as they arrive at
the parking lot of any place, everyone
knows that they're here because they're
just that obnoxious. This is a time when
we learn not to be the center of
attention,
right?
And he is not to be ignorant, unruly,
univilized.
And we will end with this statement and
we'll finish this narration tomorrow
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
And so he says, "And if anyone attempts
to argue or fight with you, then you are
to respond, I am fasting." And you are
to say it twice. What does that mean? Do
you say it to someone who doesn't
understand fasting? a average
American non-Muslim. They get out to
argue with you, say, "I'm fasting. I'm
fasting." They're going to think there's
something wrong with you. And that's
okay. It's probably enough to bewilder
them for you to deescalate the
situation. But the point is is that you
remind yourself and your opponent that
you are fasting.
And you say it, you say it out loud. You
say it in a way that will remind you,
that will snap you out of this. I am
fasting. This is not worth my trouble. I
am not going to be thirsty and hungry
all day and frustrated just to give it
to you, just to give it away, just to
cut the bottom out of my jug, if you
will.
Allah subhanahu
What
was
it?
Nice to see you.